i'm bex caswell olsen and i am the
director of book conservation at the
northeast document conservation center
today i'm going to walk you through how
my team conserves 170 year old book
this item is a record book that was
created between 1850
and 1913 and it contains marriage
records for a town in massachusetts
everything this book is written out by
hand and these records haven't been
copied or digitized this is the only
place where this information
exists and this is really important
historical information
the cover is torn in the joints and so
the front and back covers are really at
risk at falling off
the sewing that holds the pages together
is broken and so there are some pages
that have already become loose
that puts them at risk of being lost or
damaged
and then the ink that was used to write
this
book is suffering from iron gall ink
corrosion which will eventually cause
the ink to fracture and the paper to
just be eaten away by the ink
[Music]
the pages of this book got dirty over
time lots of people handling it
but also heating your house with you
know fireplace or coal
produced a lot of soot and that ends up
transferring to book pages
the first step in the conservation
treatment is surface cleaning using a
dry cleaning technique
if you don't surface clean first
of course when you mix water and dirt
you get mud and you don't want that on
the pages of your bunk we use a soft
brush
to remove dirt from the gutter of the
book and then the pages are cleaned with
the latex
sponge this isn't a sponge that you
would use wet it's something that you
use
dry and it very gently removes surface
dirt without causing abrasions or
leaving behind any kind of residue
[Music]
next we just bind the book so that means
that we remove the cover and the spine
we are using a nice sharp knife
the cover and the spine are going to be
saved because we're going to reuse them
later on in the repair
[Music]
after the cover is removed we use a
methyl cellulose
poultice to clean any old adhesives from
the spine of the text block
those old adhesives are quite aged
they've hardened
they've darkened and so we want to
remove them before we proceed
with taking the book apart and washing
we're going to let that sit under a
piece of saran wrap for a few minutes
to sort of soften the adhesive and then
we can
scrape it off or just sort of gently
scrape it off with a metal spatula
after the spine lining and any old
adhesives have been removed
we can proceed with removing the sewing
and separating the gatherings of pages
from one another
old paper can be very fragile and so
each stitch of sewing needs to be
removed
gently to avoid causing damage
before the pages can come in contact
with moisture of any kind we want to
test the inks to make sure that they can
withstand that
and we also want to test the iron gall
ink for the presence of free iron irons
if it tests positive for that that means
the ink is corroding and we need to take
some extra steps to slow that process
down
the inks in this book did test positive
which means we're going to be treating
it later on i know that washing paper
sounds kind of scary but if it's done
properly it's very safe
each page is placed on top of a piece of
non-woven polyester fabric and that's
going to provide support for the paper
while it's in the bath
and then we spray it with a 50 50
solution of water and ethanol
this helps to relax the paper and open
up paper fibers
[Music]
after about 10 or 20 minutes the tray
is drained and you can see a lot of
discoloration will come out in the first
bath so the water will be quite yellow
we'll repeat that process and change the
water until the water runs clear
after washing is complete we'll do
another bath in a
calcium phytate solution to stabilize
the iron gall
inks then we can rinse them with
filtered water
and move on to the next step
[Music]
because any sizing in the paper was
removed during the washing process we
need to resize it
this helps to add strength to the paper
and also provide some additional
protection
for the inks we use a diluted gelatin
solution
which is applied to damp pages in a thin
even layer
the size pages are then placed onto
felts to air dry in our drying rack
and after drying we can proceed with
mending
[Music]
to mend the paper we use a paste made
from purified
wheat starch and we mix that with water
and cook it while stirring constantly
and this gives us a really nice strong
adhesive that can be reversed with water
and then to make the paste even smoother
it's thinned out with water and strained
through a sieve
tears are repaired with wheat paste and
handmade japanese paper
this paper is very thin but very strong
we also need to reinforce spine folds to
prepare any breaks or weak areas along
the spine fold before we proceed with
resewing
[Music]
once all the mending is completed the
text block is reassembled and then put
in a press overnight to flatten it
before we re-sew the book is the best
time to send it off to our digital
imaging department where it can be
digitized
after imaging the text block is then
re-sewn with linen thread
which is very very strong
[Music]
after the book is sewn the spine is
pasted up with wheat paste
and that's going to help the book hold
its shape
the spine of the book gets pushed into
sort of a rounded shape with the backing
hammer
and then we put it into a jawbacker
where we back it so it kind of gives it
a little bit more
of that curved shape that you're used to
seeing in a hardcover book
next we need to add a paper spine lining
directly to the spine of the book
this is going to help it hold its shape
and prevent the book from opening
too sharply after the binding is
complete
while the spine lining is dry we can go
ahead and prepare the covers and since
we're reusing the original covers in
this repair we need to lift material on
the outside of the board
then we can reattach the covers by
inserting the sewing supports
and new spine material under that lifted
[Music]
leather
once we've got all that dry we can go
ahead and work on the inside of the
cover
and then last but not least we can go
back and touch up any areas
that are glaringly white and do any
toning to kind of help the repair blend
as much as possible
and we'll look at the item in both
artificial
and natural light to get a really good
idea of whether or not that color is
[Music]
accurate
after conservation the book doesn't
necessarily look much different and
that's actually kind of the point
we want to preserve as much of the
original material as possible
and the goal isn't to make it look brand
new it's to make it functional stable
and something that can be handled safely
[Music]
you